all might just made an incredible
comeback with a new power that seems to
rival even Primal for one this is
unbelievable and there was so much
emotion and power and nostalgia in this
chapter could this be all might's final
battle is he about to make the ultimate
sacrifice for the Next Generation let's
talk about it you guys know all this
works if you like my Matrix content you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now for
that YouTube algorithm and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch my
videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are trying to hit
2 million subscribers here on the
channel so every single subscription
means a lot by the way have you ever
wondered if Deku could have become a
villain in the mha story and I don't
mean Deku if he was like a totally
different character I mean could art
Deku the Deku we know have become a
villain under any circumstances I made a
whole video trying to come up with a
plausible scenario in which Deku The
Deco we know becomes a villain be sure
to check it out Link in the description
and in the pinned comment and let me
know if I failed or succeeded finally
this video will contain mha manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
chapter the battle between toga and
ochako concluded in a tragic and
shocking way toga seemingly sacrificed
her own life in order to save ojako and
so now presumably ochako survived and
toga is dead however we can't jump to
conclusions just yet because the new
chapter doesn't give us explicit
confirmation of toga's death instead the
latest chapter immediately takes us back
to the fight between all might and all
for one which was first set up back in
chapter 386 sold 10 chapters ago after
all for one won the fight against the
heroes at gunga he flew off in order to
find shigaraki earlier on in this Arc he
realized that the process of turning
shigaraki into his new vessel wasn't
going as smoothly as it should have and
so he has to make physical contact with
shigaraki in order to finish the job but
during the battle against all for one at
gunga Hawks observed that all for one's
de-aging process boosted his power while
also leaving him unable to suppress
negative emotions and that is when omit
made an epic return to the story we see
takauchi trying to talk all might out of
doing what he is about to do but all
might refuses to listen he says this is
how it has to be tsukauchi after all
this was always my fight all might
cannot allow all for one to reach
shigaraki before his body is rewound out
of existence and that means that all
might needs to buy time so he drives his
Batmobile just below all for one's
flight path and he goads the villain
into confronting him now for all for one
just ignoring all might and continuing
on to shigaraki would be the smartest
move but as Hawk said the de-aged all
for one is unable to suppress his
negative emotions and with how much
history he as with all might all for one
simply cannot resist confronting his old
rival after all it was all might who
defeated and Gravely injured all for one
on multiple occasions and it was because
of all might that he ended up being
incarcerated at Tartarus so even though
over one knows that his time is quickly
running out he simply cannot resist the
opportunity to finally settle the score
with almight to finally get his revenge
since we know that all might is now weak
and quirkless his decision to confront
all for one seems like an extremely bad
move with all for one back in his Peak
and all might far weaker than he used to
be in his Peak the villain should be
able to kill the hero in a matter of
seconds but not so fast all might has
one final trick up his sleeve as all for
one notices him and begins to approach
him all might's briefcase and car begin
to transform and envelop his body as if
forming some sort of superhero
exoskeleton back when this first began
happening a lot of us compared it to
Iron Man's suit of armor and we started
calling all my iron might chapter 396
confirms that our speculations were
correct because all might really does
proceed to encase himself in an Iron Man
style armored suit the chapter starts
off with all might remembering sir night
eye's Infamous prophecy that he would
experience a horrible death during a
battle against a villain now we know
that it is actually possible to change
the future the Knight eye sees and this
happened with Deku but all might feels
that if Knight eyes prophecy about his
fate hasn't been changed already then
the villain that he is supposed to be
killed by is almost certainly all for
one and the battle in which he is
supposed to die is undoubtedly this
battle all might epically proclaims I am
here as his body becomes completely
covered in his new special and extremely
high-tech armor the only part of his
body that isn't covered is his mouth
because as Nana always taught him a hero
should always be smiling and those who
smile are always the strongest the armor
itself is designed to replicate
almight's old costume when he was in his
prime and to me he kind of looks like a
cross between Iron Man and some sort of
cyberpunk Batman as all might Reveals
His new epic form his car Hercules
begins recording everything that is
happening and everything that is about
to happen I have to say that yes all
might does look extremely cool in this
costume it's clearly a reference to Iron
Man and Western superhero media but it
also succeeds in capturing the essence
of all might in his own unique way
especially with that Unforgettable and
unwavering all might smile since
Hercules is about to record the fight La
Brava thinks that they should maybe
stream it to the entire world but
tsukauchi and the police are extremely
skeptical about this whole thing
including all my decision to go out
there and fight all for one in the first
place tsukauchi has looked at the facts
and he believes that no matter how
determined and brave all mine is it is
simply impossible for someone who is so
physically weak and also quirkless to
take on a multiple Quirk using monster
like all for one it doesn't matter how
many fancy support items all might tries
to use the best the symbol of peace can
hope for is buying a few seconds or
maybe a few minutes for Deku before all
for one absolutely destroys him in the
most cruel and gruesome way as I said
earlier all for one also know that this
fight is just a waste of time for him
because the quercus all might doesn't
pose a real Challenge and since he has
an extremely tight deadline to worry
about every second he wastes fighting
washed up all might is a second he could
have been using to reach shigaraki
before his body is rewound out of
existence but in his current state of
emotional instability all for one simply
can't stop himself from engaging his
biggest rival and worst enemy and
especially not after seeing all might
smog smile poking out of that armor so a
psychotic looking all for one launches a
massive energy beam right at all might
all might commands Hercules to form a
shield the parts of Hercules that
weren't turned into all might armor are
then turned into an overpowered
high-tech Shield that forms around all
might and protects him from all for
one's attack the energy Beam still
destroys a bunch of buildings in the
surrounding area but all might is left
unscathed at least for now that said
Hercules warns almight that just that
one attack from all for one already
destroyed 66 percent of The Shield
meaning that only one more attack like
that and the shield will be completely
destroyed and all might along with it
even though this is a scary Prospect all
might isn't rattled at all and he
continues to smile on the other hand or
the lack thereof all for one has also
suffered some blowback from his own
attack the energy beam was so powerful
that it seems to have disintegrated his
own right arm up to the Elbow but of
course we know that over one has the
ability to regenerate his own body and
that is exactly what he begins to do
right away nevertheless this makes all
for one even more angry and instead of
launching another long-range attack he
flies downward in order to get closer to
all might by doing this all for one is
lured into all might trap all might uses
an attack called black whip to trap all
for one with a dozen powerful mechanical
ropes and these ropes are infused with
electricity in order to hinder all for
one's attempts at Regeneration all might
calls the electric attack charge bolt
before reeling all for one in with a
technique he calls cellophane and he
then rushes All For One using special
anti-gravity boots of some kind a movie
called Sugar Man so as all might engages
in what could be the final battle of his
life he is actually shouting out his
students and their quirks including of
course Deku coming
honestly I really enjoyed this aspect of
the chapter all might developed an
extremely powerful armored suit and he
based its powers on the quirks and
abilities of his own students it's a way
to honor them and also to show them how
much Faith he has in them and their
abilities real talk this is pretty
beautiful and emotional when you think
about it and it would hit even harder if
it turned out that all might will have
to make the final sacrifice during this
fight almight says that all for one
strategy has always been to launch
clumsy long-range attacks until he
weakens his opponent and then he would
just proceed to steal his opponent's
Quirk but since all might is now
quirkless all for one's tried and true
strategy is not going to work back
inside the police HQ tukuchi is shocked
to see how well all might is doing and
how good of a fight he is putting up La
Brava even teases him a little by saying
like oh so what were you saying oh
Mike's gonna die in a few seconds back
on the battlefield all might explains
that he really wanted a chance to fight
one last time and so he came up with the
idea for an armored suit and he had it
custom made for him by some special
friends from the United States back when
all might lost his master 12 for one and
he was forced to flee to America he met
a really good friend there and now that
friend and his daughter have given him
this gift the ability to smash all for
one once and for all the friend that all
might is talking about is of course
Professor David shield and his daughter
is Melissa Shield they were both
introduced in the first mha movie but
they've also been directly referenced in
the manga now in this chapter Melissa
finally makes her full appearance as we
see her monitoring the fight on a screen
and she is clearly very anxious to see
how well the armored suit is going to
hold up all might also speaks directly
to tsukauchi he says that as his best
friend tsukauchi should know that all
might never goes into a fight thinking
that he will lose and the chapter ends
as the symbol of peace goes on the
attack against his greatest rival all
for one in fact he uses deku's famous
kick-centric shoot style to deliver a
powerful kick right to all for one's
face and all might calls this attack
shoot style smash on that epic and
heartwarming note this chapter comes to
an end wow what an incredible legendary
comeback for our boy all might for so
long he has been out of commission due
to becoming quirkless and due to how
weak his body was but this chapter
proves that he is still the iconic hero
that everyone loved and respected even
though this armor probably won't last
long against all for one it really is
great to see the legendary all might in
action one last time now of course the
big question is this is this the moment
that all might sacrifices his life for
the next generation and dies while
fighting all for one is this the moment
in which sir Knight eyes Grim prophecy
finally comes true personally I'm
leaning that he really might die here
and that his heroic death will become a
great inspiration for all the heroes
including Deku and that is why they will
end up winning the war against the
villains what do you guys think is all
might about to go out in an epic Blaze
of Glory or could he still somehow
survive and end up hooking up with
deku's Mom which is what we all want
finally from a World building
perspective it's really interesting to
see modern technology becoming so
Advanced now of course the world of mha
has always been futuristic compared to
our own world so they've always had more
advanced technology but so far the
characters have relied heavily on quirks
in all the major battles could we be
reaching a point where modern technology
begins to rival or even surpass quirks I
mean all might's armor seems to be
capable of copying a bunch of different
quirks very effectively which almost
makes him equivalent to a multiple Quirk
user so could armors of this type be the
future what happens if like every
quirkless person has the option to
become Op with one of these suits could
quirks become unnecessary let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
below if you enjoyed this mha video and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch my
videos regularly but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and subscribe right now we're trying to
hit that crazy 2 million subscriber
number so every subscription counts and
of course subscribing is completely free
finally don't forget to check out my
video in which I created a scenario in
which the Deku we know actually became a
villain Link in description and in the
pinned comment as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys